but instead I said do you think I'm
playing games the terror sent me ain't
gonna stand for that so my first
time terrorizing anyone I'm going balls
to the wall
[Music]
[Applause]
you guys might know is probably the best
thing that ever came out of Staten
Island you guys from the show
Impractical Jokers on truTV I want to
tell you guys a story about a time I
took a wheat edible it's a story of the
first and the last time that I saw
Stacey whoo okay so I get quiet down
stepchildren no I'm kidding I got a
package delivered to my house it was
addressed to Stacey whoo
I don't know Stacey you never heard of
her never met her but the address was my
address so I'm thinking okay it's a
mistake I'll toss it to the side I'll
deal with it later weekend comes I take
a weed edible later that night I'm
chilling oh my god let me open up this
package see if there's a contact info
for this Stacey see if I can let her
know that I have our stuff so I open up
the package sure enough her address is
in our email address and it is a pair of
pants women's size 6 sateen dress pants
black from Ann Taylor Loft so I'm like
I'm gonna get Stacey her pants back so I
open up my email and I type her email
address in there right right in the
subject I have your pants
and I'm about to tell her you know just
drop me a line I'll give him guarantee
you know but then I thought wouldn't it
be great if I wrote her a ransom note
for them so read edible that's what
happens I'm like of course it would be
great so that's what people do they
write ransom note so I get out my
entertainment weekly's and I just
thought chopping away five hours for
five hours I cut letters out of years
worth of entertainment weekly magazines
it was a work of art and I taped it to
the pages and I scanned it into the
email and I'm about to hit Send and I'm
like this is not how ransom notes work I
have to send her a picture of the pants
food I got them shits and I thought
wouldn't it be great if I was in them of
course it would that's why I'm here
tonight so I get myself in these pants
it took minutes that's a long time to
get into pants but I got this body into
those size six a teens and I take some
pictures of myself and I realized I'm
bare chested and I'm like oh that's kind
of weird I don't want her to get the
wrong idea about this ransom note
I want this ransom note to be on the up
and up so I put on a shirt a tie a
jacket shoes I really clasp this ransom
note
I really do about to take a picture
myself for them and I said ah this is
not how this work she can't see my face
so I said wouldn't it be great if I was
in the ski mask I know it's awesome so I
put on a ski mask I think a bunch of
pictures of myself I upload this all
into the email I hit Send and I am so
proud of myself
because this is what life is okay a lot
of you don't know how to live people
don't know how to live I figured it out
this is it so I just go to bed I dream
great dreams and I wake up in the
morning it's like Christmas morning to
me I run straight to my laptop and I
open it up to see if Stacy wool has
received my correspondence and if she
wrote back and she did and I'm going to
read you now what she wrote back to me
this is really creepy a man sending
pictures wearing women's pants and a ski
mask I'm filing a complaint with UPS
I'll have the authorities tracked you
down to where the pants were delivered
and charge you with robbery and possible
terrorism no I did not I never in my
wildest dreams I think this was possible
terrorism I thought there's gonna be a
hoot like a little light whoo not a
possible terror she goes on they look
for people like you you son of a bitch
I don't know who you are I don't know
what you want this truly isn't funny and
if you're looking for peanut butter I
don't have any I'll get to that in a
second I'm in over my head I'm in over
my head it's obvious I should have said
this is a joke take your pants but
instead I said do you think I'm playing
games the terror sim ain't gonna stand
for that
so my first time terrorizing anyone I'm
going balls to the wall okay
I do everything I do to the best of my
ability if I'm possibly terrorizing you
look the out and I just sent her a
bunch more photos okay so then I step
away from the lapse I was the first
thing I did that day it did nothing else
so I went to my phone for the first time
and I opened it up and I had a text from
the night before
at 10:32 p.m. this is before I dabbled
with any of this other stuff and the
Texas from my landlord Stan Lee who
lives right below me and this is what
his text said he said hey buddy
was there a package delivered last
Monday and left on your porch it's for
my girlfriend Stacy
I felt the same way about the same exact
way I'm like ha ha ha there's no way
he's finding out about this I don't care
what I have to do I'm getting rid of the
pants I'll take the pants down
to a ravine I'd shoot him
that'll you get rid of stuff I'm gonna
do it and then I realized oh I sent her
then though from my email address
it's got my first last at two middle
names in the title so I have to confess
I have to come clean to stand so I call
them on the phone I'm like Stan it
sounds as a matter of fact I do have the
pants and if you want to meet me on the
side of the house I'll give them to you
also I gotta tell you something I got to
tell you something so he meets me on the
side of the house
he's a Cossack thanks so much I'm like
Stan no problem I even emailed alig no I
had him he's like you're the best I'm
like hold on just hold on just let me
finish I said stand somewhere in there
I felt it apropos to also write her a
ransom note for them he's like what are
you talking about like it's exactly what
you think and I knew I knew he was gonna
ask you well what did it say and so I
brought the ransom note to the side of
the house to read to him right there in
the driveway and I also brought it
tonight
[Applause]
this is it this is living says hello I
have your pants you guys I'll do it
every five things hello I have your
pants check the picture for proof Bink
agree that then the ransom note should
have ended there allow me to read you
the next 18 pages in order to get them
back safely I am going to need one 15
ounce jar of skippy all natural honey
peanut butter smooth this is the wheat
edible talking I'm allergic to peanut
butter I know what you're thinking
peanut butter yeah peanut butter so what
this is about me right now
bitch this really isn't the time for you
to be judging me about the peanut butter
I have your pants to be honest I felt
silly asking for the peanut butter but I
gathered myself and here we are peanut
butter is delicious and I'm out of it
I'm now explaining myself to her for no
good reason I could have asked for a lot
worse than peanut butter I don't even
know what the implication was there
I don't even question myself so let's
just move on put the peanut butter in an
unmarked duffel clearly all of my
knowledge of ransom notes has come from
the movies I don't know what an unmarked
duffel is what is it what is it Mark's
duffel there's a mark I don't know but
don't send that to me in a
mark duffer deliver to my home no later
than noon on Friday every day that I do
not receive the peanut butter I will
wear your pants with a different cute
top
she's giving me no choice
your move people forever
[Applause]
that's nice in here that's how I felt I
was elated I said to him I also I also
sent her a photo to prove I had him and
he was like let me said and I showed him
on my phone but for you guys I went to
Kinko's
[Applause]
I call that terrorist casual yeah I got
your pants Loretta it's no biggie just
what I think it was my first terrorizing
I kept it light he said what did she say
I said she said she was gonna call the
authorities and charged me with robbery
and terrorism
he said holy what did you say and I
said oh I just said do you think I'm
playing games and I just fired off a
bunch more photos fine
look this one this one cuts deep this
one's like I'm straight relax your mom's
that arrives in you I'm literally
wearing the pants in this situation
moment of silence and then he gracious
oh by the way Kinkos no questions not
employees not a word
but he graciously said look I will tell
her how him tell her I'll try and hash
it out to you and then a year and a half
later I'm walking out of my home down my
driveway and a female's walking up it
and we meet in the middle and she says
to me are you the guy that had my pants
this is a moment of truth for me so I
dug very deep I looked her in the eye
and I said I never got the peanut butter
that's a story the first and last time I
ever saw Stacy whoo thank you guys
[Applause]